Xin chào mừng các bạn đến với khóa học
excel miễn phí từ cơ bản đến nâng cao
dành cho người mới bắt đầu được thực
hiện trên kênh YouTube gái Excel bài số
9 kỹ năng lọc và sắp xếp trước khi bắt
đầu vào bài học ngày hôm nay mình sẽ
giải bài tập của bài số 8 hôm trước nha
các bạn sẽ thích vào số 8 Để bạn xem ở
câu hỏi nên ok các bạn Thúy Nga khi bạn
mở cái file lên nếu như nó hiện cái biểu
tượng này thì các bạn phải tích vào cái
enable ép tinh rồi này Đây là do Excel
nó bảo mật tôi thì nó sợ là cái file của
này nó có cái vấn đề về bảo mật gì đấy
thì nó sẽ khóa lại nó không cho các bạn
chỉnh sửa nhá các bạn chỉ xem thôi Bây
giờ các bạn muốn chỉnh sửa thì các bạn
phải tích vào cái nabo st ở đây đấy thì
đầu tiên mình sẽ làm cái see Today trước
nhắc đây thì cái ngày hôm nay thì bạn
xem dùng để làm Today các bạn bằng Today
các bạn tát nhá này sau đó các bạn bấm
enter cái ngày mình ghi video này là
ngày 26 tháng 10 đấy bạn tích vào đây
Đấy gọi thấy chưa Đây là ngày 2
Ừ thì tùy vào cái ngày thực hành của các
bạn nhá Thì cái này thì hàng của bạn
khác thì cái kết quả đây nó sẽ trả về
cái ngày khác ở đây là mình dùng cái hàm
tôi đây mà tiếp theo là các bạn sẽ tính
số tháng nhá đúng ạ Các bạn sẽ bằng Vì ạ
số tháng thì bạn có thể dùng cái hàng
biết ít nhá Đấy ít có mở ngoặc lại thì
đi mà diện cái sát đây chính là cái ngày
vào làm ở đây đúng không phẩy còn cái S
chính là cách làm thu đây các bạn tác
các bạn đóng ngoặc đơn lặng để xong cái
làm tôi đây để phẩy tính số tháng là các
bạn mở ngoặc kép ra con điện chị mm là
tiếng anh nhắm mắt lại là số thả bạn
đóng ngoặc kép ạ Con đó hoặc đơn lại các
bạn enter dậy thì như vậy số tháng làm
việc đã là được 35 tháng rồi đúng ạ thấy
số năm cũng tương tự các bạn có thể dùng
cái hàng bếp này sẽ chọn mở ngoặc bát ít
là gì Cái ngày và làm ở đây là cái U22
phẩm để thu đây cao dán tem nhá các bạn
đóng ngoặc đơn lại để song hành Thu đây
phải số nam là dịp các mở ngoặc kép các
bạn gọi chữ yy viết tắt của chữ Yêu
tiếng Anh lại còn đó hoặc các bạn đó đơn
khi enter để như vậy bạn này đã làm được
2 năm tại vì ở đây là tháng 11 mà trong
khi mình đang làm cái video này là tháng
10 nó chưa tròn 3 năm thì nó chỉ là 25
và bao nhiêu ạ 25 và 11 tháng không các
bạn xanh ấy sẽ xong này nhá Bây giờ giả
sử mình có doanh số vì tính tổng Đúng
không các bạn sẽ bằng xăm này rồi gọi ấn
tem nhất thì bạn Bôi đen toàn bộ các
doanh số đây và các bạn enter lại thì
như vậy Xong rồi Đây là 700.000 tư khác
Xóa anh Nhát nếu như mà các bạn bấm phím
tắt thì các bạn chỉ cần bấm ăn bằng thôi
đấy thì nó sẽ tự động nó sẽ xăm toàn bộ
các dữ liệu ở trên đó nhé để gọi em từ
đây này nó cũng ra là để xem nhà tư sản
KS ở đây là Trung bình thì tính trung
bình các bạn sử dụng cái hàng Everest
nhá chọn bằng Everest để gọi ẩn mũi tên
xuống và gọi ở Pháp
Ừ thì kệ trung bình ở đây các bạn sẽ Bôi
đen toàn bộ vùng dữ liệu mà các bạn cần
tính trung bình lại gọi enter thì nó sẽ
ra chúng mình Đây là 64 Tiếp theo là cái
hàm cao nhá lại các bạn có thể bằng cái
hòm cam hàm cao là cái hàm đếm số đó
cộng saponin ở đó
khi cài đặt từ c4dc 14 là các bạn enter
thì như vậy đây có 11 giá trị đúng không
Nhưng giả sử các model từ poc3 thì nó sẽ
trả về kết quả gì cho thích đút vào đây
các bạn sẽ tay C4 bằng C3 lấy đoạn Thấy
chưa nó Bôi đen cả doanh số thì kết quả
nó không thay đổi nhá Nó rất là 11 Tại
vì sao tại vì cái ô này là cái chuỗi hay
là Tech nó sẽ không Nếu nhà cái hàm cao
ấy nó chỉ đến số thôi em ví dụ bạn thay
cái gần chỗ bằng số 12 thế nhắc nhở Thế
chứ nó sẽ tăng lên đấy bằng cái số bất
kì thì nó sẽ tăng lên Tại vì nó đến đến
số thôi Thì bây giờ mình sẽ ăn Đô undo
Đấy nếu như đây là kiểu chuỗi thì nó sẽ
không đến làm cao không thì nó chỉ đến
số nhé tiếp theo là Hà mít theo ít là
Thiện Giả sử đây là cái doanh số mục
tiêu ví dụ mục tiêu là 50 Thì bây giờ
mình sẽ kiểm tra xem những cái doanh số
nào mà thực hiện ở đây mà đạt nhá đại
lớn nhất đạt thì bạn sẽ ghi là Đạt Còn
nếu không đạt thì họ sẽ ghi là không đạt
đúng không gọi cho bà mít phải có bạn sẽ
pháp này thì ít cái biểu
thực hiện nếu nhưng mà cái doanh số ở
đây tức là cái oc6 là doanh số tương ứng
ở đây này mà lớn hơn lớn hơn hoặc bằng
cái mục tiêu ở đây chính là cái Oh B1
thì các bạn phải ấn F4 để cố định cái ôm
một này Tại vì sao lại phải cố định vob1
tốt là mình sẽ áp dụng công thức này cho
cá cái ô dưới này cho nên cái mục tiêu ở
đây mình không muốn nó di chuyển xuống
dưới đúng là mình muốn nó cố định cho
nên các bạn ấn F4 lại thì lúc này nó sẽ
hiện cố định lại đến ở đấy còn thấy dựng
đô la trước hàng của chiếc cột Ừ đúng ạ
Nếu như mà nó lớn hơn 50 thì cần phải
con sẽ trả về kết quả gì Các bạn bỏ dép
ra một các bạn sẽ ghi là Đạt Đạt kế
hoạch nhá các bạn đóng phép bạn lại phải
nếu như ngược lại mà không lớn hơn kia
thì bạn xem một phép nha chọn ghi là gì
cũng không đạt để cậu sẽ đóng ngoặc kép
lại và gọn thân đóng ngoặc đơn để xong
Hà mít để mình sẽ enter để như vậy bạn
này 31 là không đạt đúng không Mình sẽ
kính chụp vào đây Đấy có khá là nhiều
bạn không đạt bây giờ ví dụ mình thay 50
bằng 10 cái gọi thời gian thì tất cả đều
đạt hết này ví dụ Mưa
a = 200 đi đấy bạn thời gian tất cả đều
không đạt hết đấy nhưng ví dụ là 60 đi
lại thì sẽ có người đạt và người không
đạt Ok mình sẽ quay về cái 50 ban đầu
nhá Tiếp theo là cái Hà men nhá mình sẽ
kết hợp gì ạ bây giờ cái mục tiêu của
mình là diện với những cái loại hàng mà
là áo và mục tiêu lớn hơn 40 lại thì
mình sẽ là Đạt nhá ấy thì bằng cách nào
mình trước phải dùng cái Hà mint Đúng
rồi còn lại thì mình sẽ ghi là không đạt
đi hoặc còn lại thì mình cho bỏ trống
nhá các bạn sẽ bằng điện mình sẽ bằng
cái Hà mít này còn mở ngoặc ra các bạn
sử dụng cái Hà mint hàm s là gì nó sẽ
kết hợp nhiều điều kiện đúng không đầu
tiên là gì Cái loại hàng ở đây ấy phải
băng diện bằng cái áo đây thì cái áo đây
là cái Ovi có phản ứng F4 để cố định các
bạn phải như vậy mình đã xong điều kiện
lôgic thứ nhất nhá đến cái điều kiện
luôn thích thứ hai là thì cái mục tiêu
là cái doanh số ở đây này tương ứng rồi
đây này phải lớn hơn hoặc bằng gì ạ bằng
cái mục tiêu đây là
ở đây là cái Obi B1 các bạn sẽ nhấn F4
để cố định B1 này lại đấy như vậy cái ô
tham chiếu là B1 và B2 mình phải cố định
hết nhá Bây giờ gọi cho đóng ngoặc đơn
lại là xong cái hòm em này nếu như mà nó
thỏa mãn cái điều kiện hai cái biểu thức
lôgic ngày tôi là nó thỏa mãn em em này
bằng chuối còn phải có ghi là gì khoản
tích lũy chẳng hạn thế nhá Đấy cạn chóng
khép lại phẩm Còn nếu như không đạt kế
hoạch thì bạn để cái quạt trống lên các
màu hoa kép nóng bằng kẹp luôn cho đóng
khép lại con enter đấy Bây giờ còn thích
đu phần cảm thấy chân như vậy Ở đây này
áo ấy bạn này tháng 8 là đàn này áo 48
là Đạt và áo là 50 đạt đấy ví dụ mình
thay cái mục tiêu bàn ghế bằng 60 đi đấy
thì như vậy chỉ có cái bạn áo này là cái
doanh số 88 là Đạt Còn cái áo này là mục
tiêu là nhỏ hơn 60 đẩy áo dài cũng vậy
rất là hay thấy ví dụ là 40 đi đây thì
lúc này tất cả đều là Đạt nhé tương tự
cái hòm O cũng vậy nhé thì lo thì nó
ngược với cái trên tức là việc cứ là vũ
thì à còn
ý là mũi thì là rèn Lớn năm 50 thế nào
nó thỏa mãn một trong hai điều kiện này
thì nó giống hệt với cái chết thôi mình
thấy em o bằng ít Ít mở ngoặc thì mình
sẽ dùng cái nào ngon à thì cho là diện
Tức là nó sẽ thỏa mãn một trong các điều
kiện ở đây thì điều kiện thứ nhất là gì
nếu như mở đây D6 mà bằng bằng cái loại
hàng mục tiêu ở đây thì các bạn sẽ nhấn
F4 cái hàng mục tiêu này tức là nó cứ
bằng vũ thì mình sẽ ghi là Đạt rồi đúng
không Hoặc là gì hoặc cái danh số đây là
cái kéo này mà lớn hơn hoặc bằng bằng
cái mục tiêu ở đây là B1 các bạn F4 nhất
để họ sẽ đóng ngoặc đơn lại để xong cái
Hà mong này phải tức là nó sẽ thỏa mãn
một trong hai điều kiện này để cắt mở
két ra con thích thích vào đây rất là
Đạt này đóng ngoặc kép lại phải tại mình
sẽ mở kẹp bằng cách luôn còn nếu ngược
lại thì mình sẽ trả về kết quả trắng gọi
đó hoặc đơn lại nha Rồi enter đấy gọi
thế chứ ở đây là Mũ Mặc dù là nhỏ hơn
doanh số và người nhỏ 50 rồi nhưng mà do
đó là loại mũ đâm ra là mình thích đã
đạt ở đây này có tích lũy vào đây này
cảm thấy rằng cứ vũ thì nó là Đạt
có bao nhiêu gà còn lại là diện nếu như
không phải là mũ thì vẫn thấy chưa quần
và áo thì lớn hơn 50 là Đạt đây là tất
và 48 thì là không đạp đúng không Vì là
gì ạ vì không phải là Mũ và cũng không
phải là lớn hơn hoặc bằng 50 cho lên ở
đây là không đạt thì kết quả là chẳng
nhắc lại có hai các bạn này này kết quả
trắng tiếp theo là phê lúc cấp thì cái
hàm Vlookup mình cũng làm nhiều rồi đó
Đây là ạ tên bây giờ mình cần tìm doanh
số đúng không các bạn sẽ bằng Vlookup
thì đầu tiên là tên bạn này đúng không
phẩy bảng giá trị rò đây phải cái cục
trả về mình cầm tiền lên số là của số 2
phẩy tìm chính xác sẽ là không có bạn
đóng ngoặc đơn lại là nó sẽ ra 9.2 còn
Chắc kiểu này nếu như mà dùng in Bac Mat
nha đẩy Ví dụ mình dùng Index của maddie
thì bạn sẽ bằng Index này Index của gì
đầu tiên là gì mình sẽ Bôi đen toàn bộ
vùng dữ liệu này phải cái hàng trả về là
gì mình sẽ dùng cái hạt mét mét của gì
của cái tên này phải trong nhẹ trong cái
vùng dữ liệu tên rồi đấy ạ
các bạn phải không ngừng tìm chính xác
các bạn đóng ngoặc đơn lại được xanh làm
mít phải cái cột vào đây nó chỉ có một
cuộn duy nhất thôi thì các bạn phải điền
luôn là của số 2 tên là cuộc số một
người đó hoặc doanh số đà của thứ hai họ
sẽ đổ mặc đơn ạ đấy bởi ví dụ trai Lê
Hồng bằng Lý Tuấn các bạn ngáy rất phải
ở đây còn Coffee bạn nhấp phải vào đây
cậu biết đấy Bạn thấy chứ doanh số đều
thay đổi theo hi Ok như vậy là mình đã
xong cái câu hỏi của bà con chiếc nhé
còn đóng lại Ok Bây giờ mình sẽ sang bài
số 9 tìm như vậy là mình đã kết thúc cái
phần các hàm rồi Hôm nay mình sẽ làm cái
bài đầu tiên của các kỹ năng thì kỹ năng
đầu tiên của mình hôm nay mình sẽ giới
thiệu các bạn là filter sọt và cả
fnfilter tức là lọc sắp xếp và cả lọc
nâng cao và gia vị vào đây thì nội dung
hôm nay mình sẽ hướng dẫn các bạn là 5
Phần đầu tiên là mình sẽ làm về filter
thứ hai là sắp xếp thứ ba là sắp xếp
nhiều cấp Thứ tư là fa-filter và thứ năm
là fa-filter nâng cao đây là
ý của mình nha mình có trường ngày tháng
này khu vực nhà phân phối đây là sản
phẩm vào đây là doanh thu đây Ở đây các
bạn sẽ lăn chuột xuống này còn thấy chân
dữ liệu của mình rất là lớn thì đầu tiên
là mình sẽ giới thiệu với các bạn về
filter tức là lọc nhá các bạn sẽ tích
vào một ô bất kỳ trong cái vùng dữ liệu
này Đấy sau đó bạn vào với thẻ data các
bạn tích vào cái chữ filter cái hình cái
phễu đây này có thích của chữ Peter đấy
còn thể điều chỉnh ai kia các thích vào
chữ filter thì bạn thấy chưa có các nút
tương ứng ở đây đấy thì tất cả cái cục
nó sẽ đều có nút tương ứng ở đây này Đây
là cái dữ liệu liền nhau thì có nha Còn
cái dữ liệu đây nó sẽ bị cách rời cái
cục cờ này Cho nên những cái dữ liệu đó
rồi thì nó sẽ không có đúng không đấy
Còn nếu như bạn muốn bỏ cái filter này
thì có bạn lại thích lại và các phím tư
này thì nó sẽ bỏ cái phim tôi đi lại Bây
giờ mình rất thích vào đây để mình làm
về Peter bây giờ mình sẽ tìm hiểu cái
ngày tháng trước nhá họ sẽ tích và cái
biểu tượng filter đây này Đấy thì ngay
lập tức nó sẽ hiện của cái cửa sổ im
tươi cho các bạn nhá thì đầu tiên là gì
ạ
Ồ thông minh nó sẽ nhóm này thì ở đây nó
sẽ có hai cái năm là năm 2019 và 2020
hạn thế nhá thì nó sẽ nhóm lại Bây giờ
các bạn sẽ thích và cái dấu cộng này đấy
thì nó lại nhóm lại các thánh thì trong
các tháng thì có các ngày nào để rõ tích
được đây Đấy nó rất là hay tức là nó sẽ
tự động nhóm và cho các bạn để các bạn
có thể dễ dàng chọn đúng không lại nếu
như bạn rất thích mà cái trên cùng này
là sẽ e con thì nó sẽ bỏ trọ toàn bộ nhá
Nếu như mà muốn chọn toàn bộ các bạn
thích rồi đấy nếu như bỏ chọn thì gọn
lại thích rồi Đây này bây giờ giả sử
Mình muốn chọn diện chọn cái tháng 1 của
năm 2020 tại thì các bạn anh xuống dưới
là như vậy 2019 cũng bỏ chọn rồi đó lên
220 thì bạn sẽ tích và cái gelly này
chắc là nó sẽ lựa chọn toàn bộ cái tháng
1 của năm 2020 lại còn nếu như bạn muốn
chọn thêm là gì Tháng 1 và tháng tư đi
lại của lam hay không em ơi và ví dụ lạc
tháng hiện tháng 2 của năm 2019 nữa để
như vậy Mình có 3 tháng á thì họ sẽ
thích ok đấy thì như vậy toàn bộ các dữ
liệu này gọn này chưa được lọc
a tiếp theo làm lọc theo khu vực cũng
vậy nếu như mà gọi tích ở đây rồi các
bạn sẽ bỏ chọn ôn đi đợi thì như vậy
toàn bộ khu vực đã không được chọn các
bạn tích vào đây thì là lựa chọn toàn bộ
khu vực đúng không Đây cả tích chọn một
lần thì bỏ còn tích thêm một lần nữa là
chọn đấy Cứ như vậy nha các bạn có thể
chọn được rất là nhiều cái tùy chọn lấy
ví dụ mình chọn miền Bắc và miền Trung
và hạ thế nhá để gọn sẽ bấm ok thì nhà
phân phối cũng vậy nha nhà phân phối các
bạn có thể chọn bất cứ nhà phân phối nào
Ví dụ mình chọn Viettel đi để gọi bằng
Ok hãy sản phẩm cũng vậy nha các bạn có
thể chọn bất cứ cái sản phẩm nào nhiều
cũng được nhá hoặc là một hai sản phẩm
đều được cái doanh thu này cũng vậy nha
đây các bạn có thể vào năm một filter
này cả thích vào đây nhá đấy các bạn sẽ
tích vào ở đây nó có một số tự chọn là
bằng này Đây là không bằng ví dụ mình
chọn cái glitter gian rất là chọn lớn
hơn nha ví dụ mình chọn là lớn hơn 50 đi
chợ gạo sẽ bấm ok thì như vậy nó chỉ lọc
những cái doanh số và lớn hơn 50 Thì đấy
là cái cách mình dùng filter rất là hai
ạ thì tùy vào yêu cầu các bạn có bạn có
thể
có sản phẩm nào có bạn có thể dùng
filter đây sau đó bạn có thể copy dữ
liệu phim tư này Đấy ví dụ mình copy từ
ngày thôi nha bạn nhớ thì phải copy đấy
các bạn có thể tạo xong cái sim mới ở
đây này Đấy còn tích vào đây các bạn
enter đấy Bạn thấy chưa thì nó sẽ copy
toàn bộ các dữ liệu mà các bạn lọc lúc
đấy lại rất là hai ạ Bây giờ mình sẽ xóa
đi nhớ chất phải đi đi lại mình quay lại
cái sim ban đầu thì bây giờ muốn clear
thì các bạn có thể tích và cái cờ Liên
này đợi thì nó sẽ còn liệu toàn bộ cái
phần mà mình tin tới lúc nãy thì như vậy
toàn bộ dữ liệu ở đây đã được trả diễn
ra hết rồi nhắc nó sẽ không còn phim tư
thế nào nữa nó chỉ còn cái biểu tượng
filter thôi đấy toàn bộ dữ liệu đây là
Suy nghiệm ban đầu của mình luôn thì
ngoài ra cái phim tư này nó có một cái
hay là thì các bạn có thể sắp xếp nhé ví
dụ các ngày tháng có thích vào đây đấy
thì ở đây nó có đầu tiên là sắp xếp từ a
đến z này chắc là từ nhỏ đến lớn đây đấy
còn sắp xếp ở đây là từ lớn đến nhỏ Ví
dụ mình sắp xếp từ nhỏ đến lớn đi Thấy
chưa thì toàn bộ cái vùng dữ liệu ở đây
nó sẽ vị tha
Ừ cái phần ngoài này tên là những cách
cuốn hát này nó sẽ không bị ảnh hưởng gì
đây đây toàn bộ các phần dữ liệu mà nó
liên tiếp nhau như thế này thôi thì nó
mới bị tác động nhá Đấy nếu như bạn sắp
xếp thiện từ thiện lớn nhất đến nhỏ nhất
này vẫn thích ở đây đấy thì lớn nhất đến
nhỏ nhất thì tương tự các bạn có thể sọt
theo bất cứ cái gì cũng được rồi theo
nhà phân phối thì cũng được vì các bạn
nhé tiếp theo mình sẽ giới thiệu các bạn
là sọt nhiều cấp tính là gì ạ Giả sử
mình sao chép khu vực Nhưng mà nếu như
mà khu vực bằng nhau tướng nào giả thiếu
đây có rất là nhiều Miền Trung đúng
không Thì mới ngại yêu Tiên tiếp theo là
mình sẽ giọt nhà phân phối đại Nếu như
nhà phân phối lại bằng nhau thì mình cứ
Tiên tiếp theo là gì Là ngày tháng hoặc
là sản phẩm và cuối cùng là doanh thu
chẳng hạn thứ nhất Tức là mình sẽ dò
theo nhiều cấp đúng không đấy thì gọi
làm như thế nào để có bạn sẽ thích của 1
cô bất kỳ trong cái vùng dữ liệu này và
các bạn tích vào cái chữ sọt này vẫn là
trong cái thẻ data nhá các bạn tích vào
cái chữ trò này đấy thì nó sẽ hiện một
cái cửa sổ ở đây tức là nó sẽ có nhiều
cấp này Đầu tiên là nó sẽ có mặc định là
một cấp nhất là sọt 3 soạn bài là gì Ví
dụ mình chọn cái khu vực
Ừ đấy thì cái xeon ở đây là gì Resort
The level of Đúng không Nó có một số tùy
chọn là sạch theo cả màu sắc để soạn
theo cả Phong chứ lại thì ví dụ mình soi
thêm values thôi ở đây là thứ tự nhá lại
từ từ nhỏ dần đến lớn hoặc là gì từ lớn
xuống nhỏ lại Tùy các bạn nhắc Ví dụ
mình Đạt Ờ diện từ nhỏ đến lớn đấy Đấy
giả sử nó cách cấp độ này là xóa theo
khu vực rồi luôn các bạn bún s thêm một
cái các lỗi nữa thì bạn chọn là KS level
đây Đấy tức là nếu như mà khu vực bằng
nhau ở đây mình có rất là nhiều khu vực
miền Trung rồi thì mình sẽ dò theo diện
các bạn có thể tùy chọn bất cứ cái gì
yêu tiên thứ hai ví dụ cái ưu tiên thứ
hai của mình là nhà phân phối đi Đấy
mình Ví dụ nhà phân phối là từ Z đến A
thế là từ viện từ lớn xuống nhỏ đấy các
bạn có thể s theo bất cứ cái level làm
nha Có thể tích vào đây ví dụ mình thích
cho doanh thu nữa đi Ví dụ mình có ba
cái level này thôi nhá lại vẫn là theo
vali ví dụ từ lớn túi nhỏ đi nhá lại còn
nếu như trong trường hợp các bạn muốn
cái doanh thu này nó lên trên tức là nó
ưu tiên hơn các nhà phân phố nha thì gọi
nhà thuốc ạ chọn rẻ quạt tích là cái mũ
Hiến pháp này đấy thì con nó sẽ đẩy cái
phần doanh thu lên ưu tiên thứ hai thì
ưu tiên đầu tiên nó sẽ sắp xếp theo khu
vực Nếu khu vực bằng nhau thì nó sẽ sắp
xếp từ doanh thu và ưu tiên cuối cùng là
nhà phân phối bây giờ các bạn muốn cái
doanh thu nó nhảy xuống cuối các bạn
tích vào cái doanh thu này các bạn sẽ
thích cái mũi tên xuống rồi đây này thì
như vậy cái danh thu nó bị đẩy xuống
cuối lại còn nếu như bạn muốn xóa một
cái cấp nào đấy nha ví dụ mình chỉ ưu
tiên khu vực và thì doanh thu thôi mình
xóa nhà phân phối đi thì gọi phân tích
và các nhà phân phối là các bạn muốn
delete đi lại như vậy nó chỉ sắp xếp
theo hai cấp thôi Nếu mà khu vực bằng
nhau thì nó sẽ xuống đây thứ hai là
doanh thu đấy các bạn thích Ok Đấy đấy
là Cách Cách thứ ba là mình sắp xếp theo
nhiều cấp tiếp theo mình sẽ giới thiệu
với các bạn về Advanced filter cái này
rất là hay đấy ạ đấy thì cái pan Peter
Giả sử bây giờ mình muốn chiết xuất cái
danh sách là gì danh sách là cái nhà
phân phối là Viettel
ở đây thì mình làm như thế nào thì các
bạn sẽ copy cái tiêu đề nhá bạn nhớ là
con copy cái tiêu đề Coffee Ví dụ mình
sẽ viết vào đây lại mình sẽ chiết xuất
từ đây có anh ấy thì phải gắn kết vào
đây Đấy mình có nhà phân phối rồi đấy
các bạn sẽ ghi là diện Viettel đấy thì
để cho chắc chắn nha cọ sẽ copy cái nhà
phân phối ở đây cho nó chắc chắn bởi vì
đôi chị bạn gọi thì nó sẽ bị sai khác
mình viết vào đây Đấy Bây giờ mình muốn
chiết xuất danh sách các nhà phân phối
là Viettel thì mình làm như thế nào mình
sẽ dùng fa-filter nhất đấy thì đầu tiên
là gì ạ Đầu tiên các bạn sẽ vẫn là vào
thẻ data nhá các bạn chọn rẻ các bạn sẽ
chọn cái đây này SV này đấy thì nó hiện
một cái cửa sổ ra là s Exciter thì cái
lý trang của mình đi thì thông thường nó
sẽ mặc định là cái vùng dữ liệu ở đây
lại hoặc làm gì là nếu như mà Nó là một
cái vùng khác nhau ví dụ nó đang ở vùng
này còn thích đây vẫn thấy chưa thì nó
Nam nào ribbon nhấp nháy mẹ các bạn sẽ
Bôi đen Cái vùng
Ừ đấy các bạn Bôi đen Cái vùng tiêu đề
nha Bạn giữ cần Dương ship vào mũi tên
xuống thì như vậy là cái list lên của
mình đã lựa chọn toàn bộ cái vùng dữ
liệu ban đầu của mình rồi đúng không đấy
Bạn thấy nó cũng nhấp nháy này tiếp theo
các bạn sẽ tích mà Cái dưới này là cái
vùng điều kiện clitoral lên đây này Đấy
cách vân điều kiện là diện các bạn sẽ
Model cái tiêu đề nhà phân phối và cái
chữ Viettel ở đây để tức là Thiện nó sẽ
lọc cái vùng dữ liệu này theo cái điều
kiện là nhà phân phối Viettel ở đây đúng
không Còn nếu như các bạn 1 chiết xuất
nha ra một cái vùng dữ liệu khác thì họ
sẽ tích chọn và cái copy to anan
location thì thông thường những cái
event inter mình hay chọn cái này tức là
mình sẽ chiết xuất ra một cái vùng dữ
liệu nào đấy đúng không chiếc xe con sẽ
thích một cái ô là copy tu tức là các
bạn muốn copy đâu Ví dụ Bình copy ra cái
ô là ov4 này để họ sẽ tích vào cái gì bố
mình nhá hãy gọi sẽ bấm ok đấy Bạn thấy
chứ như vậy là toàn bộ các dữ liệu đây
còn thấy cho tất cả nhà phân phối
Viettel nó được copy ra đây chỉ có nhà
phân phối Viettel thôi
ở đoạn nâng lên lại cảm thấy chứ tất cả
chữa Viettel thôi Đấy em còn xin tôi rất
là hai ví dụ mình có hai nhà phân phối
mình muốn nhà phân phối Viettel và gái
Excel ở đây đúng không Thì bạn gõ thêm
là cái chữ cái xe lên đây Đấy Và Các Bạn
Làm lại nhé Bây giờ giả sử vì xóa cái
phần chiết xuất này đi cạn nhảy cho phải
các bạn delete đi bây giờ mình muốn
chiết xuất cái danh sách là nhà phân
phối của Viettel và gái xem thì rất là
đơn giản các bạn sẽ copy thêm cái nhà
phân phối gái sao xuống dưới này như vậy
là cái vùng điều kiện của mình là diện
là cái tiêu đề nhà phân phối và hai cái
nhà phân phối mà bạn cần chiết suất là
Viettel và gái Excel đúng không Thì Đầu
Tiên Tốt nhất là con sẽ tích vào một ô
bất kỳ trong cái vùng dữ liệu mà các bạn
muốn chiết xuất này đây này Đấy con tích
và một hết chỉ đây sau đó con vào thẻ
data các bạn tích vào cái chữ s pha này
đấy thì mặc định nó sẽ Bôi đen toàn bộ
cái vùng dữ liệu còn thấy giờ toàn bộ
các vụ việc nhấp nháy này chính là cái ô
thì từ B4 đến cái f498 này này cái phần
điều kiện lấy bạn thấy cho
ở nhà diện tích ở đây thì lúc nãy là
mình nạp tiếng hát Mười đến tháng 11 là
bây giờ còn sẽ Bôi đen lặng để từ diện
từ H 10 đến h12 đây Thế cảm thấy chứ Nó
sẽ thay đổi thứ hát 10 đến tháng 12 này
có tích vào đây để mình chiết xuất ra
một cái danh sách mới các bạn tích vào
đây là thích và cái ô ô copy tung á sau
đó bạn chọn ô mà các bạn muốn chiết xuất
đến này Ví dụ mình chọn vẫn là cái og bố
mày đi đâu ạ Bạn sẽ bấm ok đấy Vợ thấy
chứ lúc này cây nhà phân phối gái xe và
Viettel đã được chiết xuất rồi đấy nó
chỉ chiết xuất hay các nhà phân phối là
Viettel và cái xe thôi nhé Còn ví dụ Ông
FPT và ông viên PT là do không chiết
xuất mình sẽ xóa đi các bạn nhấn chuột
phải vào delete đi tiếp theo là gì mình
sẽ giới thiệu với các bạn vẽ Phan Thị
Tiên nâng cao đấy ngoài các nhà phân
phối là Viettel và gái xe này Bây giờ
mình muốn thêm điều kiện nhận diện là
khu vực này Cậu nháy chứ phải copy khu
vực các nháy chuột phải vào đây thì tốt
nhất là cái tiêu đề là quan trọng nhất
thì bạn copy và các bạn Tuyết cái phần
tiêu đề nhé ví dụ là gì
Ừ nhưng mà nhà phân phối Viettel ý thì
tôi phải là gì là khu vực là miền Bắc
hẳn thế nhá đấy các bạn sẽ gõ tên miền
Bắc vào đây thì bạn chú nha kinh gõ đây
nó cũng phải giống hệt chị ở đây này thì
tốt nhất là gọi copy còn các bạn tự tin
thì nó có thể gõ tại ví dụ Các bạn có
thể thêm cái phần doanh thu nữa cũng
được lại có ảnh hưởng gì đấy Các anh thu
thì tốt nhất các bạn copy cái phần tiêu
đề đấy cả copy các bạn nhảy cho phải đây
mình kết đi thì để đảm bảo nó giống là
cái tiêu đề nhé nếu như và doanh thu là
Viettel khu vực miền Bắc và mình lọc là
diện là phải lớn hơn lớn hơn 700 đấy Còn
cái điều kiện đây là nếu như mà gái sao
ấy thì là gì nếu như mà gái xe mà cũng
nên bác không thì bạn gõ là miền Bắc đây
Nếu như bạn không phải miền Bắc đấy mà
gọi để như thế này thì nó nhà phân phối
cứ gái xe thì nó sẽ chọn hết còn ở cái
hàng này thì nó là đồng thời tức là nếu
như mà nhà phân phối Viettel thì khu vực
là miền Bắc và doanh thu là 700 và doanh
thu là lớn 700 thì máy lọc còn cái Hà
Ừ chắc là cái điều kiện tiếp theo là gì
Và Diện Nó sẽ kết hợp cả với cái trường
hợp là nó chỉ quan tâm đến nhà phân phối
Viettel thôi nếu như thế này ấy Thịt ba
cái điều kiện trên này là đồng thời còn
cái này là họ đấy thì cái cái xe nó có
thể là ba miền và doanh thu nó là bất kỳ
đấy Còn nếu như gái xe mà bạn vẫn là
miền Bắc thì các bạn vẫn mong muốn là
miền Bắc thì bạn có tiếp ở đây là miền
Bắc đấy và có diện nếu như cái xe doanh
thu về nhà địa nhỏ hơn 500 hạ thế nhá
thì mình mới lọc dậy thì như vậy thế
phần điều kiện ở đây các bạn phải chú ý
mình sẽ giải thích lại nhé Thì cái điều
kiện từng hàng ở đây là riêng biệt nhau
và nó sẽ xảy ra đồng thời Ví dụ ở cái
hàng này là nó Đồng thời nhau là cứ
doanh thu cứ nhà phân phối Viettel thì
là khu vực miền Bắc và doanh thu là lớn
700 thì nó mới lọc tương tự đây cứ nhà
phân phối là gái Excel khu vực miền Bắc
và doanh thu nhập 500 thì nó mới chiết
xuất đúng đấy và cũng còn chút nhá cái
phần tiêu đề ở đây nó không cần đúng thứ
tự đâu lại thứ tự nó có thể bất kỳ Ví dụ
nhà phân phối các bạn có thể
ở đây cũng được tiếp theo là khu vực
tiếp theo là doanh thu cũng được nó
không ảnh hưởng gì cả nhé Bây giờ mình
sẽ làm các bạn cái phần lọc nâng cao như
thế này các bạn sẽ tích vào một ô bất kỳ
trong cái vùng dữ liệu ở đây nhé Sau đó
các bạn có thể data các bạn sẽ chọn để
ewa đấy thì gì ạ Cái vùng dữ liệu ở đây
này Nó sẽ gì vẫn là mặc định toàn bộ ở
đây đúng không cái vùng điều kiện bạn sẽ
xóa đi Bạn nuôi em đã xóa thì cùng điều
kiện đi Các bạn chọn lại nhé đấy toàn bộ
cái cùng điều kiện ở đây là từ H 10 đến
j12 các bạn rất thích vào cái phần diện
copy to another location này các bạn sẽ
tích vào cái ô ô coffee tu những ví dụ
mình copy ra tại ô l6 này là các bạn xem
Ok Đấy Bây giờ mình sẽ kiểm tra nhé mình
sẽ tích và mô bất kỳ cho cái vùng chiết
xuất này các bạn tích và cái filter bây
giờ mình sẽ kiểm tra nhà phân phối là
Viettel hạn thế nhá các bạn tích vào cái
nhà phân phối các bỏ chọn đi mình chọn
Viettel không đấy thì Viettel ở đây mình
chỉ có miền Bắc và doanh thu lớn hơn 700
đoạn thấy chứ nó mới chọn tiếp theo là
cho ví dụ gái Excel như các bạn chọn
ngài serre các bỏ Viettel đi đấy thì như
vậy thế bạn gái xe này còn tích vào khu
vực Đấy chỉ là miền Bắc thôi để cái điều
kiện những gái xe và miền Bắc thôi đúng
không và các doanh thu nhỏ 500 để chọn
tích vào cái doanh thu lại còn thấy cho
con lăn xuống này thì cái giá trị cuối
cùng là cái giá trị lớn nhất thì cái lớn
nhất của nó chỉ là 442 thôi đúng không ạ
tất cả đều nhỏ 500 đấy cảm thấy em khác
rất là hai ạ đấy là cái lọc nâng cao nhé
Thì bây giờ mình sẽ chỉ cho các bạn cái
phần lọc luôn cao nữa là gì ạ bây giờ ví
dụ Xóa ngay đi Các bạn muốn chọn thì bây
giờ ví dụ nếu như nó thỏa mãn các điều
kiện này Mình chỉ lấy gì ạ Lấy khu vực
nhà phân phối và doanh thu Thôi nhé mình
bỏ các cái phần sản phẩm và mình lấy thế
là sản phẩm đi Chẳng hạn Tức là mình sẽ
lấy 4 cái trường này thôi mình bỏ cái
trường ngày tháng đi đấy thì mình làm
như thế nào đấy thì các bạn chỉ để bốn
cái phần tiêu đề đấy thôi các bạn xóa dữ
liệu đi bạn giữ kiểu trang trí của mũi
tên xuống gọi đi hết đi đây tức là mình
sẽ bớt lại các phần tiêu đề ở đây để lát
nữa mình sẽ giải thích cho các bạn Tại
sao ở đây lại là lọc nâng cao
ạ bây giờ cạn tích về đây có bạn sẽ
kreide nhá mình sẽ lấy hết đi bên mình
sẽ làm mới các bạn xem này cái này lọc
nâng cao là gì ạ Và bây giờ mình sẽ là
các bạn nhá và sẽ tích và một ô bất kỳ
trong cái vùng dữ liệu này các bạn vào
thẻ data mình vợ FA rồi thì nó sẽ hiện
một cái đầu tiên là cái list lên đây con
sẽ xóa cái đi nhá cái nick đây nè đây
con sẽ tích và một cái ô của cái vùng mà
các bạn cần chiết xuất đây này Đấy con
sẽ bấm cân chân ai đấy cậu thấy cho khi
các Đốm quen chữ cái thì toàn bộ cái
bảng này cái vùng dữ liệu bắt đầu của
mình đã được lựa chọn đúng bằng từ B4
đến cái f498 này các bạn sẽ xanh ấy phần
điều kiện để cái phần điều kiện là nó
giống như trước rồi luôn rồi Còn tôi xóa
đi chắc các bạn lại Bôi đen lại đây phần
điều kiện ở đây Thế có thích chọn cái
phần diệt copy to another location các
bạn sẽ xóa cái đi Rồi bây giờ mình sẽ
Bôi đen toàn bộ các phần tiêu đề này
Thế thì tại sao mình lại Bôi đen toàn bộ
cái tiêu đề này tức là mình chỉ chiết
xuất những cái tiêu đề này thôi còn
những cái kia đẹp khác thì mình không
chiết xuất ví dụ như là cái ngày tháng ở
đây mình không cần trích xuất đúng không
Còn nếu như các thích và cái chữ inquare
này thì là gì ạ là nó chỉ chiết xuất
những kết phần giống nhau thôi Tớ nào
thì ở đây nó có bốn cái phần khu vực nhà
phân phối sản phẩm và doanh thu là nhá
thì giống nhau thì nên sẽ xóa đi mà nó
với một bây giờ mình sẽ bỏ ra lại đi đấy
là cái tùy chọn nhà tù các bạn Tại bây
giờ gọi sẽ tiếp cho ok đi đấy bạn thấy
cho như vậy nó sẽ copy bốn cái chiêu này
tôi và nó sẽ không copy cái ngày tháng
nếu bạn thấy không rất là hai ạ Ok bây
giờ mình muốn chiết xuất ở một cái xích
khác tình hình ảnh như nào thì lúc nãy
mình trước Suốt ngày ở mỗi cái sít này
và file này thôi Đúng bên mình sẽ xóa đi
Đấy chọn thủy ngân Lúc nãy mình chiết
suất là gì trên cái xin à bây giờ mình
muốn chiết xuất ra một cái ship mới đúng
không Ví dụ đây đây là cái xít mà mình
muốn chiết xuất nha nhá Đấy bây giờ mình
muốn chết ra cái thứ ba thì cái việc đầu
tiên là gì Các bạn phải vào với 93 này
Nếu như các bạn
khi chúng ta cái sít nào thì đầu tiên
bạn phải vào cái gì đấy trước đã nhé sau
đó gọi thể data Các bạn chọn FA đấy thì
một cái cửa sổ sbank inter đã được hiện
ra đúng không cái phần listening ở đây
này các bạn sẽ tích vào cái ô lít lên
rồi đây sau đó các bạn xanh cái chi ban
đầu của mình là sĩ một sau đó giữa các
bạn sẽ Bôi đen cái phần tiêu đề của cái
vùng dữ liệu này đấy các bạn giữ cần
ship và nhũn xuống thì như vậy là gì cái
list lên ở đây nó sẽ lựa chọn toàn bộ
cái vùng dữ liệu rồi đúng không thấy
cảnh xuất kích vào cái cùng điều kiện ở
đây lại sau đó các bạn lại quay lại cái
sĩ một ở đây thì bạn sẽ lên trên này nhá
thì các bạn lại Bôi đen Cái vùng điều
kiện ở đây đấy tiếp theo là diện con sẽ
chọn vào cái ô ô copy to analysen tại
thì nó lại quay về cái xít mới tạo đây
là chị Ba nó các bạn sẽ thích vào cái ô
ô copy tu và các bạn sẽ cho vào cái ô mà
các bạn thân chiết xuất Ví dụ mình muốn
chiết xuất ra cái ôm B2 này đúng không
để cậu sẽ bấm ok nói còn thấy chứ như
vậy là mình đã chiết xuất ra một cái sim
mới là gì đây là khu vực phía Bắc này
Đây là mình sẽ kiểm tra lạ
ở lại các bạn sẽ vào data cạn và filter
lại nếu như mà nhà phân phối Viettel
mình bỏ gái sao đi đại Viettel nó miền
Bắc và lớn hơn 700 đấy nó chỉ có 2 cái
ngày này thôi Đấy Bây giờ mình sẽ vào ví
dụ nhà phân phối là gái xem nhé các bạn
bỏ Viettel đi đấy thì như vậy gái sao
này Đây là chỉ miền bắc đúng rồi đúng
không cái doanh thu cũng vậy các bạn ăn
xuống dưới này để doanh thu lớn nhất nó
chỉ là 442 đâu nó nhỏ 500 rồi đợi rất là
hay là như vậy mình đã chiết xuất ra một
cái sim mới nhá lại Ok như vậy là mình
đã xong cái bài hôm nay bây giờ mình sẽ
xem cái bài về nhà nhé đây các bạn xem
mở cái câu hỏi này lên đại thì ở đây
mình cái vùng dữ liệu của mình vẫn là
cái phần dữ liệu chia thôi nhưng mà đỡ
mình sẽ có 5 câu hỏi là trích xuất theo
nhà phân phối này ở đây để các bạn sẽ
làm nhé đấy nhá ở đây mình sẽ có năm cái
câu hỏi cho phần về nhà ở
a ghi chú là gì Các bạn sẽ làm ở trên
cùng sheet và các sheet nhá Đây đây là
bài tập về nhà cho các bạn nhá các Thúy
Nga mình sẽ để cái phần link tải file
thực hành trong phần mô tả phía dưới
video thì các bạn tốt nhất là quản Tải
về các bạn vừa theo dõi và thực hành
cùng mình nếu như bạn nào không biết
cách tải về thì các bạn có thể tham khảo
thế bài đầu tiên của mình nhé để các bạn
biết cách tải về trong cái video Đấy
mình đã hướng dẫn khá là chi tiết rồi ạ
Ok Bây giờ mình sẽ đóng cái câu hỏi lại
nhá như vậy là mình đã kết thúc bài học
ngày hôm nay ở đây cảm ơn các bạn đã
theo dõi các bạn nhớ đăng ký Kênh để cập
nhật video mới nhất của gà cũng như chia
sẻ để giúp mọi người cùng họ cũng xem
nhé Xin chào và hẹn gặp lại ở
ừ ừ